bonjour et bienvenue sur des gonades la
leçon avec comme présentateur
aujourd'hui stéphane laborde bonjour
stéphane alors bonjour donc des gones à
la leçon spéciale aujourd'hui le thème
l'opposition à l'heure et loi qu'est ce
que c'est que l'opposition alors
l'opposition nous en avons déjà parlé
c'est donc un thème qui revient
fréquemment dans les finales de pions et
alors l'opposition ça consiste à mettre
son roi en face du roi et demi pour
gagner du terrain
alors ça donc c'est un thème qui
viennent dans les finales dans les
finales de pions notamment donc où les
rois sont les seules pièces active de 10
ans à part les pions voilà c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il y a opposition en
finale option principalement puisque le
roi donc étant la seule pièce restantes
sur l'échiquier on peut avoir ce qu'on
appelle l'opposition alors ça vient
justement du mouvement du roi qui se
déplace dans une case par une case
donc quand on met notre roi en face du
roi et demi donc on prend ce qu'on
appelle l'opposition on en a déjà parlé
c'est à dire qu'on va l'obliger à jouer
un coup et a cédé du terrain ça c'est
toute l'idée donc l'opposition qu'est ce
que c'est en gros c'est un thème c'est
une technique en fait deux finales qui
permet soit de gagner du terrain soit de
dalé soit à gauche ou à droite en fait
c'est oui donc en résume ainsi je
commandais ses maîtres le roi en face et
j'oblige les oblige des noirs a joué en
fait c'est ça j'aime ce qu'on appelle un
du besoin
oui enfin on est obligé de jouer un coup
qu'il faut qu'il va pas être bon c'est
là que je vais être obligé de m'éloigner
du lieu de bataille
voilà alors l'opposition et
particulièrement efficace quand on a
deux objectifs 1 à gauche et à droite on
l'obligeait à choisir son côté de
défense et on va de l'autre côté ca c
c'est une des utilisations et y en a
d'autres donc je propose tout de suite
qu'on voit un premier exemple alors
allons-y alors donc tu nous a concocté
un premier exemple c'est interdit un
exemple très simple
donc on voit de roi le roi 1,5 pour les
blancs 1re un g7 pour les noirs et donc
un pion f 4 pour les blancs et un pur
9,5 pour les noirs alors qu'est ce qui
va se passer dans cette pétition les
blancs vont essayer de ramasser
naturellement ce pions noirs
ils vont donc jouer roy h5 angers 5 ils
prennent l'opposition c'est à dire qu'il
se mette face au roi et demi mais tout
de suite ce n'est pas le facteur le plus
important
qu'est ce qui est très important ici
c'est que les noirs doivent jouer un
coup ça c'est clair
et qu'au prochain coup les blancs vont
vraisemblablement manger ce pion et
comme on l'a déjà vu dans les finales de
roi et pion contre rouen donc ce qui va
arriver ici il faudra justement quand
les blancs vont prendre ses pions noirs
prendre nous-mêmes côté noir
l'opposition donc ici la défense est
l'unique défense enfin disons il ya un
mauvais coup et que des défenses il faut
jouer roi f8
on va voir pourquoi une [ __ ] j'aurais
tendance à jouer bref cette eau est tout
à fait alors wave sarthe et la faute
alors c'est ce qu'on va voir puisque
après 3 prend pions
maintenant ici on n'amène maintenant le
roi sur la case à 100 c'est à dire qu'on
l'amène à acquérir attendant on a décalé
on a décalé d'un coup alors si j'avais
joué avec sept tout de suite je vous ai
été obligé de partir en fait voilà alors
c'est on peut revenir dans la position
dans cette position là si un jour où
elle fait maintenant qui est une autre
possibilité il reprend pions f5 l'organe
noires et lacées à moins de jouer c'est
la différence était replacé noir de
jouer donc à moi alors que tout à
l'heure c'est tselem verse tout à
l'heure c'était inverse donc ici comme
les noirs sont obligés de jouer ils sont
obligés de dalé soit gauche qu'on va
envisager ici les deux joueurs recettes
à ce moment là on fait roi g6 ça on a
déjà vu dans la leçon précédente
pourquoi ça gagne puisque maintenant le
pion n'a plus qu'a avancé très
simplement
ici c'est pas bon en revanche en jouant
au premier convoi fuite 3.5 est
maintenant aux apps est là on force les
blancs à choisir leur côté avant nous
sert qu'en fait on est enfin de gagner
du temps et lang l'ont pleinement en
europe et l'opposition
mais tant que les blancs choisissent de
venir ici on garde l'opposition restant
devant eux
et là on est dans la finale élémentaire
ou action contre rouen on sait faire nul
si on se réfère à la leçon de la semaine
précédente
ouais je peux plus avancer mon roi
devant le pion pour préparer le terrain
à la chute bloqué par le roi et demi
voilà on est si j'amène le pian hauteur
de mon roi je sais que je peux plus
gagner
voilà le canton mais l'option la hauteur
du roi c'est à dire tout ça sur la même
sur la hem traverse s'est très
facilement nul il suffit de laisser
droit devant les cases où l'option
devrait avancer et on va faire nul
facilement donc ça c est un premier
exemple on peut revenir sur la pression
de départ qui est donc la suivante ici
roger 5 il ne faut pas jouer bref cette
puisque ça permet trop plein de garder
l'opposition
il faut jouer trois fuites les blancs
prennent l'option est maintenant au rêve
set et là c'est les noirs qui vient de
prendre à leur tour le donk les noirs
arrivent à annuler dans ce cas là donc
là c'est une teinte m d'opposition pris
par les noirs pour annuler la partie
voilà alors évidemment ce qui est très
important c'est de maîtriser ça
complètement ce qui fait qu'en partie
rapide ou un blitz là où on n'a plus
trop le temps de calculer pouvoir jouer
d'instinct au roi fuite et non par
wife's est dans cette position donc
premier exemple très simple on va en
voir un autre s'il réfute un peu ce cas
là c'est là on a avancé des pions d'une
case plus donc plus haut lors il alors
les plus proches de la promotion
maintenant on est d'accord l'an sachant
ça change tout pas parce qu'on peut pas
jouer roi bref neuf voilà déjà on ne
peut pas jouer ça et en plus de toute
façon cette finale est gagnante puisque
quand le roi donc ça c'est en fait c'est
un supplément à la finale droite
relations contre roye qu'on n'avait pas
vu la dernière fois il faut absolument
voir ici même si les noirs ont
l'opposition quand le pion et sur la
quatrième rangée et bien il n'y a pas de
problème ça gagne de manière forcée
quel que soit le trait donc ici il ya
aucune différence les plans n'ont qu'à
jouer 3 6 donc là évidemment il faut
venir en 8c la défense logique même si
ça perd quand même c'est le bon réflexe
apprendre revenir sur cette case là
maintenant pousse ses pions
le roi reste sur la tête de promotion on
pousse encore c'est le seul exemple où
le pian peut avancer pour faire l'âme
c'est le contre exemple le roi est objet
quitté un peu la défense de la promotion
recettes suivent dame est ici ça gagne
alors revoyons un peu la différence
c'est que dans cette position on reste 6
3 et frites les noirs prennent
l'opposition mais malheureusement comme
le pion est déjà à trois casses de
promotion ou ses terres qu'il est sur la
rangée où il se trouve actuellement il
n'y a pas de problème la finale est
gagnante dans tous les cas quel que soit
le joueur qui est très donc ça c'est un
contre exemple un fait c'est le contre
exemple en fait l'opposition en défense
ne suffit pas puisque les blancs donc à
pousser les pions d'accord maintenant on
va passer à des exemples un peu plus
compliqué un peu plus parlant
celui là alors qu'est ce qu'on voit ici
est plus compliqué il ya deux options
contre 2 alors effectivement ce qu'on a
dit en début de début d'émission est
très vrai pour qu'il puisse y avoir
opposition il faut que les pions soient
bloqués certes il détourne sont pas
bloqués on peut toujours prendre
l'opposition
mais là le joueur joue un coup
on sur un terrain autres l'échiquier et
reprend à son tour l'opposition cerqueux
en fait ce terme on est obligé de jouer
le roi c'est ça marche que si on est que
si on n'a que le roi qui peut jouer
voilà tout à fait c'est ça si l'adoption
ailleurs qu'ils peuvent jouer ça ne
marche plus il n'y a plus d'opposition
alors ici très important voyons un peu
ça les pions sont bloqués donc
l'objectif pour chacun des camps si on
veut gagner cette position c'est d'aller
chercher jeudi à rennes l'option le plus
éloigné donc pour les blancs le client
f5 et pour les noirs le pion d'angers 3
puisque c'est le seul qu'on pourra
apprendre
évidemment les pions se défendant
mutuellement quand ça qu'il joue et l'un
d'eux cette position alors dans ces
conditions c'est au plan de jouer et il
y à un coup gagnant alors que tous les
autres coûts font nul nous qu'est-ce qui
se passe voyons par exemple le premier
coup un mauvais coup on amène le roi sur
la tête ces quatre là on ne prend pas
l'opposition la proposition donc très
vite c'est les noirs qui vont le faire
ils vont mettre le roi face à notre roi
ils vont le mettre en c6 et là on peut
tout essayer maintenant avec les blancs
il n'a plus rien à faire on n'a plus
aucune chance de passer
après trois des quatre rois des six là
on ne peut pas aller sur les cases aux
quatre puisqu'elle pions on ne peut pas
monter puisque le roi noir contrôle
donc on revient en france et 4 il
revient à ces 6 et là vous voyez
toujours ce fameux barrage de trois
cases
ils nous empêchent complètement passée
est évidemment si on recule la série
noire qui peuvent la télé voilà ça va
permettre au noir d'avancé enfin là ils
ne peuvent toujours pas gagné mais
effectivement ils ont avancé d'un cran
et ils ont toujours gardé cette
opposition puisqu'ils contrôlent encore
les trois cases face au roi nous croit
ces cas n'est pas une bonne option dans
cette position ce n'est pas le bon bout
pour faire attention
le bon coup voilà c'est de prendre
nous-mêmes l'opposition directement avec
roy en d4
alors là tu peuvent faire les noirs ils
ont plusieurs mauvais choix c'est à dire
que ils peuvent aller soit à gauche ou à
droite
bon il faut il faut rester près des
pions en ont en principe oui alors on va
regarder tout de suite cette solution
qui est pardon immédiatement au roi ces
six paires à cause de roi ou cinq en
masse tous les pions et après on gagne
facilement
on la veut
on ramasse les options et là comme on
l'a déjà vu dans une édition précédente
de finale de lyon quand on a deux pions
d'options donc en finale depuis hongrois
et d'options contre roye ça gagne
pratiquement à tous les coups pour ne
pas dire à chaque fois donc ici pour
voir si cette année à chaque fois dans
la mesure où le roi noir ne peut pas
prendre un pion directement voilà il
faut pas non plus que les pions soient
doublés enfin il ya ben oui il ya des
très rares exceptions facile et plus en
plus il est à lyon soit liée soit
suffisamment séparer maintenant une
emprise du roi noir ça gagne facilement
voilà oui oui c'est clair donc ici
croisé au ras des quatre jouer au
premier coup le roi noir évidemment
reste près de ses pions et là nous
allons introduire un nouveau concept
celui des cases critique alors pour
prendre ce pion là il y a une règle très
simple il faut réussir à se trouver sur
la colonne ce vacancier sur la plongée
sur la même rangée que l'option avec
notre roi donc ici évidemment on va
aller sur la case c5 et la saison
prévient donc c'est bon là on est sur la
casse critique le roi noir ne doute pas
une seconde et tonique et là le la
grosse pointe c'est que les noirs ne
peuvent pas prendre position dans cette
position ils ne peuvent pas leurs cinq
semaines en face à nantes 3 puisqu'il ya
le kg au f4 donc ici les noirs ne
peuvent pas reprendre l'opposition et on
va voir qu'il n'y a plus de solution
pour eux pour s'en sortir
par exemple à nous le roi toujours près
des puits on va rester près des pions
bref synopsis roi des 6es cna le roi
blanc est en train de contourner
complètement 7
cette formation est on à l'opposition en
plus on à l'opposition le roi noir doit
partir
mettons qu'il vienne angers 7 places
c'est très simple
maintenant il ya plus besoin
d'opposition qu'est ce qu'on est
vraiment trop près juste trop proche du
petit hongrois six attaques l'option 3g
6 des fonctions et là on s'aperçoit
qu'on va mettre le roi noir zigzaguant
puisqu'on va jouer trois ou cinq la case
f6 est contrôlé par le roi lacasse g5 et
contrôlée par le pion le roi noir doit
partir il doit bouger
il a donc que des mauvaises options
puisque au coude après on va prendre le
premier pion puis le suivant puis
suivant et donc on gagne facilement la
finale après on gagne
on fait sinon c'est donc ça c'est
intéressant on a vu donc pour prendre
nos pions le plus arriéré faut être sur
la même rangée que ce pion oui ça on
l'obtient en prenant une opposition donc
reprenons la finale depuis le début ici
il faut jouer trois ans le 6 c'est la
défense la plus logique
on amène nos trois ans c'est simple on
s'est mis sur les quinze critiques du
lion le roi noir ne peut pas reprendre
l'opposition il doit reculer alors bon
évidemment il peut aller sur notre carte
ça ne changera plus rien à la faire
maintenant puisque la cause est entendue
ici on vient en d5 est absolument aucun
bluff possible et bien m6 il essaie de
s'accrocher à ces cases proche de son
pion aux rois des six de toute façon il
un problème c'est qu'il ne peut n'a pas
cette quinzaine a passé 15 le pion à vis
4 est une véritable épine lui prend les
cats g7 g5 et e5 donc ici il n'y a pas
le choix il faut qu'ils déménagent
encore d'une case peut-être en 9 7
on monte en cinq ans j'ai six et on se
retrouve dans une position similaire
après rossi sont va gagner le plus bref
ça donc bref reprendre la pression
départ donc là le coup c'est prendre
l'opposition avec trois des quatre
tranches d'imposition à trois des quatre
ce qui nous permet au coup d'après
puisque là les noirs ont le choix entre
deux côtés de toute façon il va lâcher
soit la case la soie la case là il va
lâcher une de ces d'occase et une fois
qu'on sera mis dessus on sera sur les
cases sur la même rangée que le pion
noirs et là on va lui mangeait son pion
donc exemple très simple
ici les blancs gagne donc là donc
donc si je résume donc on prend
l'opposition et après on a on obtient
une taille critique soit la même rangée
sur la même rangée collections et demi
ça suffit pour gagner ça suffit pour
gagner oui tout à fait d'accord donc
bien en tout cas le thème c'est bien
l'opposition
donc les droits face à face et forcer
les noirs à jouer voilà c'est
l'impression qui nous permet de nous
mettre justement sur les pièces
critiques du pion nouvel exemple un peu
plus compliqué celui là donc là vous
voyez on dirait presque le même exemple
c'est presque le même exemple sauf que
j'ai inversé l'option g6 et angers 6 au
lieu d' étrangers 4 et l'option blanc et
et angers 5 au lieu d'être en g3 et là
ça change tout ça change tout ça change
tout pour une raison très simple c'est
que le client à prendre maintenant il
est ici côté blanc oui le plus à prendre
il est sur la sixième manche et non plus
sur la 5e et ça c'est très très
important très très grave donc là bon
c'est vrai ce que ça veut dire si donc
si on arrive à mettre le roi sur la 6ème
ranger est ce qu'on pourra gagner voilà
sont mes droits soit s'il mange et on va
gagner
tout à fait c'est ça que ça veut dire
alors ici on va on va donc essayer d'y
aller alors première étape
évidemment ne pas jouer le roi c4
puisque après roissy 6 les noirs
prennent l'opposition donc c'est ce
qu'on a vu maintenant ils ne lâcheront
plus cette opposition ils n'ont plus
aucune raison de lâcher et on pourra
plus avancé d'une seule case sait on
pourra plus prendre une seule colonne
une seule rangée donc au premier coup il
faut évidemment jouer haut rang ces
trois ans comme ça c'est l'opposition
vient le voir donc c'est ça de sa
devient automatique maintenant c'est
l'opposition tout bat marc parent par
défaut transmettre faso par défaut fait
se mettre face au vent est ici alors
voyons par exemple une défense noire qui
consisterait à jouer au roi en 17
donc là évidemment on a infléchi n'aime
pas on continue on garde l'opposition on
se barre des 5 toujours face à face avec
ses trois cases là et là on voit que
immédiatement le roi noir est obligé de
nous laisser rentrer dans son camp nous
laisser rentrer sur la 6ème branché
puisqu'il n'a plus le choix
qu'il aille à gauche ou à droite ça sera
pareil maintenant s'il vient ici c'est
cuit puisqu'on joue on continue re 5
on reprend encore la pression on
s'approche des élections il y reste
et maintenant roi des 6es l'arrivée on
va arriver à prendre le pion on est à
peu près dans le même thème que tout à
l'heure on s'est mis sur la rangée du
pion on va aller le ramasser tout
simplement il n'y a plus de défenses
c'est le exactement le même thème arrête
on se renseigne sur la rangée du pian et
le roi noir ne peut pas nous
bloqués c'est important oui c'est très
important mais doit être dans près de
notre propre opinion
oui mais ça c'est en fait c'est tout à
fait normal c'est quand il ya deux pions
face à face on se met sur la rangée du
pion et demi c'est bon c'est bon
justement parce que l'option qui en face
du pion et demi va contrôler cette case
critiqué la case m6 donc la saga n'y
envoie des si on peut continuer quelques
coups moi j'ai cette recette ou si c'est
pareil maintenant rage sept rois ici en
f6 et là on s'aperçoit que le roi noir
n'a plus de gaz
c'est toujours pareil on est donc
obligés de nous laisser l'option ou g6
emprise et ça ça gagne de manière fort
c'est donc ici gain très simple dans
cette position trois des quatre rois 17
serait une faute
il faut aller en a eu six on est très
important alors pourquoi ce coût est
très important c'est parce que les
blancs ne peuvent pas les garants 24 et
oui voilà donc ce que le voir prendre la
position
donc on ne peut pas prendre l'opposition
alors par contre on essaie de gagner du
terrain
on va venir sur la case ces cinq là on
gagne du terrain
le roi noir ne peut pas venir lui-même
prendre l'opposition alors la layan coup
il faut que je faut faire attention
alors là faut faire attention puisque
effectivement si on revient en 17 une
fois de plus les blancs prennent du
plaisir à en croire des 5 on retrouve la
position de table et on retrouve la
pression tout à leur nom donc ici il
faut pas se tromper avec les noirs il
faut prendre ce qu'on appelle
l'opposition en diagonale éloigner le
fait sur dire ça comme ça
c'était un être le roi e set alors
qu'est ce qui va se passer il ya une
case aussi du roi mais cette fois en
diagonale et ça c'est aussi une
opposition
c'est une pression des gones al pourquoi
et bien parce que quel que soit le coup
joué par les blancs c'est à dire si les
blancs viennent soit gauche soit devant
toi droite tout droit les noirs feront
linverse ses terres soit à droite soit
en montant à la différence donc c'est
bien pourtant le roi blanc sera bien sûr
la 6e ranger mais on n'est pas assez
proche de notre pays laurent noir le roi
blanc serait bien soigner manger mais
ici c'est les noirs qui prennent
l'opposition et qui sont eux aussi sur
essayez de manger est donc là qui nous
empêche d'aller ramasser ce pion
aussi s'il n'y a plus de yapi
d'échappatoire si on vient on ces sept
on voit qu'on n'avance pas où j'ai même
les noirs qui peuvent gagner une
invention
alors oui oui très très bonne très bonne
remarque ici ça serait possible que le
noir gagne dans cette finale m'enfin de
nom ce serait nulle quand même mais il
faut faire attention il faut faire
attention
ne nous enflammons pas en finale puisque
de toute façon voilà c'est très bien on
voit que tout le monde peut gagner la
finale de pions comme il ya quand même
un matériel qui est égal il n'y a pas un
déficit énorme donc là ce qu'on a vu sur
war c6 les noirs viennent et seront un
des cinq là nous avons la même position
que précédemment
sauf que c'est aux blancs de jouer et là
ça change tout puisque c'est les blancs
qui ne peuvent ou ne peuvent plus gagner
terrain où le que les noirs doivent ont
concédé les blancs ne peut plus gagner
après 3,5 suis bien entendu roi 7
ballons qu'on garde l'opposition
si le roi recul le roi avance très
simplement
donc ici je pense que les flèches sont
assez explicites dans cette position si
le roi blanc montrent laura noir va se
mettre en face si le roi blanc va à
droite de renoir va se mettre à gauche
toujours en face book ici c'est
l'opposition en diagonale l'opposition
éloignées qui gagne enfin qui fait nul
systématiquement qui feignent
systématiquement donc reprenons encore
cet exemple depuis le début puisque idc
ludique est assez important premier coup
les blancs tente le tout pour le temps
de d'annoncer deux prend tout cas on
prend la position tué trois des quatre
six et le c'est la meilleure façon
d'essayer de gagner par des quatre
propositions roi 3 à 6 c'est le seul
coup qui fasse nul puisque ce roi 17
suivrait trois des cinq qui pointent
l'opposition et qui gagne puisque là on
va se mettre sur une des cases critique
du pion enfin pas tout de suite d'abord
ce roi 7 on va encore pour l'opposition
et là on va y aller voilà parce qu'il
faut prendre la 6e ranger mes proches
les plus proches du pion possible le
plus proche du conte possible ça c'est
très important
donc voilà roy 17 fautes roy au cices
c'est le meilleur coût
c'est le seul coup même rossé 5 on
essaie quand même d'y aller et là le
boucler le couple et de cette position
c'est la défense avec 3 e set
donc qui prend l'opposition en diagonale
qui empêche les blancs d'oeufs passé et
qui empêche les blancs de passer donc si
besoin que du vent de côté noir en fait
on arrive à bloquer les blancs
complètement oui oui
donc voilà exemple suivant l'exemple
suivant et dernier exemple pour pour
cette leçon aujourd'hui les blancs on
leur envoie en c3 rendront en c6 et là
on va voir que l'opposition ne passe
plus par les cavs critique mais
simplement par le fait qu on force le
roi noir à choisir s'il part à gauche ou
à droite
n'est ce pas oui tout à fait donc ici
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et bien
évidemment bien entendu vous l'avez
deviné faut prendre le positif courant
l'opposition
leroy montant c4 le roi noir at choix
entre rester sur les côtés près de la
défense de section ou allait lancer
cette qui sembleraient plus souple ou
partir très loin alors premier choix
roye b si ce qui est le moins le moins
teigneux et on voit tout de suite on
peut naître on joue au roi des cinq là
alors là on est carrément sur la casse
critique puisqu'on va prendre le pion au
coup d'après donc c'est gagnant croisé
cette oie prend pions et là c'est
gagnant puisque on a ce qu'on appelle un
pion passé éloignés et de toute façon en
fait le pion tout seul en vaut 4
suffirait à gagner donc il ya pas de
blabla suffi puisque on peut on peut
veut jouer après au cours et après royal
6 voilà et préparer le chemin pour le
pian comme on a vu pour gagner les
finales depuis quand tout à fait donc
ici ça serait gagnant très facilement
maintenant
mettons qu'il vienne dans ses sets c'est
une autre possibilité mais ça nous
laisse évidemment la même chose avec
trois des cinq ou également avec 3,5
c'est au choix
ici dans là par contre on peut voir que
c'est pas si simple que ça parce que
vendent les noirs peuvent prendre
l'opposition et noir peut jouer 3 17
on prendrait d'un entre deux options est
de continuer à garder l'opposition donc
là là les normes l'opposition dans la
vue de tout à l'heure donc ça ces
particules ça ça c'est une finale nul
mais on a vu également dans le cours de
la dernière fois qu'on avait un pion
passé éloigner ses terres cultivables a
qui sont un rôle très important
d'accord alors est ce qu'on peut
comprendre pourquoi alors on va
comprendre pourquoi on jour où un des
cinq ici pour faire un nul
le coup c'est de garder l'opposition ces
rois 17 maintenant on pousse le pion et
non maintenant tout ce papier on n'est
pas pressé d'avancer spira bon on va
d'abord aller chercher le pion et demi
de l'autre côté et ça c'est le fameux
qui ont pas s'éloigner et qui fait
diversion et qui oblige les noirs à
revenir dessus
ici il suffit de suivre le roi suivant
leur - est-ce qu'on peut pas rejoindre
ses 7 points pour garder l'opposition
oignons peut garder encore l'opposition
mais là le problème c'est qu'après roye
b 5 en garde l'opposition on garde
encore l'opposition mais comme on l'a
dit en début d'émission
il y a deux pions passer à des adoptions
plus musclée après avoir prouvé
s'inquiète donc là le position n'a plus
n'a plus vraiment cours ici ce n'est pas
possible c'est à dire qu'après une fois
qu'on aura de plus en plus on va pousser
un client à droite
et puis si le roi à le chercher on
pousse le pion à gauche voilà qu'on
pourra pas garder les deux exactement
sur le thème du chiapas et éloignés note
finalement quand on est un pion passé
comme c'est le cas là et qu'on est en
opposition et qui reste des pions de
l'autre côté il faut pas pousser son
camp mais il faut les chercher les plans
de notre côté oui c'est à dire que ici
la finale est nul
si on essaie d'avancer notre plus ancien
est certain c'est le bio danival c'est
parce qu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure on l'a
vu avec mais il ya des pions en art à
gauche qu'on peut aller chercher donc sa
diversion ça fait diversion et donc
évidemment plus la diversion est éloigné
c'est à dire en gros il est là le pion
est très éloigné du roi noir plus eh
bien c'est à dire que si notre pions
n'était pas ici mais là déjà la
diversion serait beaucoup moins efficace
puisque le roi noir multi fait d'un coup
pour les prendre l'option alors que la
wii dès en ce moment l'uff ou trois
coups pour aller chercher trois coups
pour revenir donc le temps le temps pour
les mange espions et de est très très
long donc ici pas de pas de solution on
va chercher l'autre pions fait diversion
l'adoption passé et ça gagne très
simplement donc autres nouvelles
possibilités
après trois des cinq
oui 17 donc ça s'appelle sa perte très
simplement
autre possibilité d'impression de départ
on a vu que si le roi fainéant b6 à
perdre et puis ce qu'on allait prendre
le pion aux 5 b si c'est la case ici on
va prendre à ce moment là le pion aux
cinq et ont fait dame de manière fort ça
va peut-être voir on va essayer de
recruter parce que peut-être les
premiers ça c'est beaucoup plus
persistants effectivement conflits
persistants parce que maintenant après
roy b5
on peut jouer par exemple 3 c'est cette
lettre à logique roi prend et au revoir
ses 6 alors ici la méthode de guerre va
être la même que tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que là on l'a déjà dit on va leur
dire les finales de pions avec un pion
sur la colonne ne gagne pratiquement
jamais sauf s'il tue on peut avancer
tout ça le fait rire que deux options là
tout seul ne gagnera pas c'est une
finale nul si on fait abstraction des
d'options qui sont là donc seule
solution pour gagner c'est la même chose
qu'avant on jouera b43 b6 et là on
n'avance pas plus on pourrait l'avancé
mais on joue ça pour garder la diversion
le plus loin possible
hélas il est noir cherche à garder
l'opposition donc avec roy ses 6,5 ou le
coup qui permet de la récupérer ces
attaques à cinq récupère l'opposition
faisant diversion tout simplement là il
n'est plus trop question de position
fait dans cette finale puisque on fait
là il est question de diversion
principalement le roi doit venir quand
même garder ses options qui menacent
d'aller à dame
et là pendant qu'il y va tout de suite
on va de l'autre côté on ramasse le
dernier pion et celui-là ya plus qu elle
avancé c'est une finale
élémentaire hélas le renoir est
complètement d'un red arrow fraises
comme on dit pour arrêter le pion voilà
d'autant plus que on va intuitivement du
bon côté c'est à dire du côté qui va
repousser le roi noir on se met sur la
case et 6 à prévoir si on avance notre
pions y a plus rien qui peut l'empêcher
d'aller à dame et donc de gagner cette
partie donc royaume contreras vous savez
déjà le faire dans la leçon on l'a déjà
vu plusieurs fois
voilà alors on peut peut-être faire une
conclusion sur cette opposition
ouais donc alors moi j'ai compris donc
l'opposition sait mettre les rois face à
face à peut être défaut en diagonale
quand on n'a pas d'autre choix et suivre
les finales depuis lors dans les finales
de pions comme ça des chaînes de pions
l'idée c'est de prendre le cuir le plus
éloigné de la chaîne et de cette arrivée
à se mettre sur la même rangée que
l'opium qui défend la chaîne voilà alors
ça c'est les fameuses cases critiques
c'est à dire que y'a un pion qui est qui
défend un autre pion il faut attaquer
l'option défendant et non pas l'option
défendue ça paraîtrait logique et pour
ça il faut se mettre sur la même rangée
que ce pion c'est les fameuses cases
critique et pour y arriver on se sert du
moyen très simple quelle opposition
cirque on va se mettre face au roi et
demi le roi il va devoir bouger soit à
gauche ou à droite on va aller de
l'autre côté on va le prendre à
contre-pied à revers on va se mettre sur
les castes critique et ensuite on va les
chercher pions ça c'est effectivement
c'est une des utilisations de
l'opposition alors quand on a les rois
très éloignées comme ça par exemple
parce que là on a vu des rois tout
proche donc on a pris l'opposition de
suite mais s'il est roi sont plus
éloignés on peut calculer est de prendre
position aussi alors ça c'est justement
le thème de la prochaine édition
diagonale la leçon ça va être les quinze
conjuguer les casques en juillet c'est
une opposition qui est très très
éloignés voire même pratiquement
introuvable c'est une fête c'est
l'élément le plus difficile à comprendre
des finales de pions c'est une
opposition à très très long terme alors
est-ce qu'il faut mettre le roi ici ou
là quand le roi et demi est à l'autre
bout de l'échiquier de là où là ça fait
des différences ça fait la différence
entre gains ou nuls
dans certaines positions c'est ce qui en
fait c'est une expansion les casse
conjugué donc c'est le pompier
résistance voilà c'est ça sédition à
distance
il ya l'opposition toute bête qui est
roi face à roye l'opposition à distance
qui est donc on a vu diagonale déjà
l'impression diagonale qui est une sorte
de positions éloignées
oui l'opposition très éloignées qui est
par exemple le roi eu un contre le roi
en 1/8 ça on arrive encore à voir en se
référant aux couleurs des cases et les
casse conjugué ça devient très très
compliqué c'est à dire que là les rois
sont n'importe où sur l'échiquier c'est
en fonction de la structure de pionsat
zhu et ça sera le thème de la prochaine
émission diagonale la leçon donc vous
verrez lundi prochain
d'accord il n'y aura que ce thème là où
notre père horatio ce thème là il est
énorme il est
très difficile je pense qu'on verra un
ou deux exemples tout au plus c'est un
thème très compliqué donc pour conclure
sur sa les finales d'options c'est très
simple revoyez tous et vous je pense que
vous aurez à peu près tout compris cet
élément clé c'est très important un
final de pions elle et c'est très
important
il suffit de prendre option au début au
début de la partie vous échanger toutes
les pièces si vous savez si ces gagnants
au nul ça fait toute la différence
d'où l'importance d'un pion en fait on
comprend les grands champions qui ont
besoin de plus il gagne est parti c'est
notamment parce qu'en finale le roi
contre roye ils savent comment gagner
wild et font du chantage toujours à ses
positions gagnantes font du chantage
s'est positionné à dire que dans les
positions ils menacent dé changer des
pièces 6 ans rentre dans une finale roi
contre roy si on a bien compris tous ces
thèmes là on sait que c'est gagnant ou
pas et donc on peut on peut accepter les
changes ou pas voilà exactement
donc après on fait du chantage et pour
obtenir d'autres positions gagnantes
oui la courbe en mai très bien je crois
qu'on a fait le tour de l'opposition
donc voilà pour cette c'était que
qu'elle est c'est fait comme une
émission ça doit en faire une dizaine
dès lors une dizaine donc voilà donc on
se donne rendez vous à son prochain avec
bertrand guyard oui tout à fait l'indien
prochain pour une nouvelle la leçon sur
les casse conjugué sur les cages
conjuguée à la semaine prochaine